das ist wirklich jetzt der absolute
haben wir die position vom planet 9
wurde eingegrenzt bisher blieb der
phantom planet neuen jahr trotz
intensiver suche unentdeckt
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben aber jetzt seine exakte position
na ja mehr oder weniger mit hilfe
komplexer mathematischer modellierung
und computergestützte simulationen
eingegrenzt jetzt hat die gezielte suche
begonnen die schlinge um planet 9
zieht sich also immer weiter zu wo genau
er sich wohl befindet und wann wir ihn
wahrscheinlich endlich entdecken werden
jetzt den klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen planet neuen
erinnert ein wenig an den planeten
neptun auch er wurde viele jahre vor
seiner eigentlichen entdeckung
theoretisch bereits vorher gesagt und
zwar aufgrund von unregelmäßigkeiten in
der bahn des uranus ähnlich verhält es
sich jetzt mit planet 9 trotz intensiver
suche bleibt der riesen planet aber ein
phantom
dabei mangelt es nicht an
verschiedensten anhaltspunkten und
indizien man vermutet dass es sich dabei
wohl um einen gesteinsplaneten handelt
und dass er wohl den vierfachen
durchmesser der erde hat und maximal
zehn mal so groß ist wie unser
heimatplanet er muss sich nach ansicht
vieler forschungsteams wohl am äußeren
rand des sonnensystems versteckt halten
gemeinsame bahn abweichungen
verschiedenste objekte in dieser region
lassen darauf schliessen konkret geht es
um rund 20 größere objekte im
kupfergürtel ein gebiet außerhalb der
neptun bahn nach schätzungen von
astronomen und astronomen sind dort
zahlreiche kleine und wohl mehr als
70.000 objekte zu finden die einen
durchmesser von mehr als 100 kilometern
haben weswegen man planet 9 bis heute
trotz intensiver suche noch nicht direkt
beobachten konnte das liegt wohl an
seiner enormen distanz zur sondern
amerikanische wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen vom institute of
technology california haben jetzt
berechnet dass die bahn verblendet neuen
dem planeten zu dem zeitpunkt seiner
dichtesten erdnähe wohl noch immer
achtung 700 mal weiter an der sonne
vorbei führt als die erde das
forschungsteam hat viele informationen
über den mysteriösen riesenplaneten
analysiert und mit hilfe von co
hüther modellen komplizierte
simulationen erstellt ihr ziel ein
computerprogramm soll ihn ganz konkret
die position von planet neuen nennen so
dass er dann ganz einfach mit einem
großteleskop entdeckt werden kann
genauso wie damals bei neptun in einem
blog artikel schreibt einer der
beteiligten forscher mike brown dass
sein team das komplette letzte jahr
analysiert hat wie planet 9
mit anderen planeten und dem rest des
sonnensystems interagiert zitat wir sind
schon ein gutes stück weitergekommen
seine mögliche position am himmel
einzugrenzen
dieser ort befinden sich ziemlich nahm
sternbild orion was eigentlich recht
komisch ist da der orion schließlich zu
den bekanntesten sternbildern zählt die
eigentlich fast jeder kennt zitat ende
schon in naher zukunft wieder hoch genug
am himmel steht will das forschungsteam
mit der systematischen suche am himmel
beginnt mike brown und seine kolleginnen
und kollegen geben sich also äußerst
zuversichtlich die exakte position des
mysteriösen phantom planeten eingrenzen
zu können
dennoch sagen sie auch dass sie zurzeit
weniger informationen über die lage von
kliniken haben als die astronomen und
astronomen damals die im jahr 1846
neptun entdeckt haben
das ergebnis ihrer forschung hat das
amerikanische team online veröffentlicht
denn sie wollen so heißt es in dem blog
dass möglichst viele bei der suche
helfen oder sind nicht wenige mindestens
zehn weitere unabhängige forscherinnen
und forscher suchen derzeit fieberhaft
nach planeten jäger geht es um halte ich
euch natürlich zu allen entwicklungen
bei planet 9 auf dem laufenden wenn er
kein video dazu verpassen wollte und
auch zu allen anderen themen dann genau
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die gurke denn nur dann
werdet ihr auch sicher informiert wenn
es neue videos gibt und hier geht es
weiter mit planeten nachgewiesen
da gibt es weitere infos zu planet 9
wenn er mehr infos haben wollt
draufklicken und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran